this is dave klein reading for richard
wakeling
the dark picture's anthology house of
ashes has to justify setting in a way
few horror games do
while supermassive games unsettling
anthology previously tapped into teen
horotropes and puritan era paranoia with
mana medan and little hope house of
ashes looks further afield in terms of
both influences and geography taking
place during the invasion of iraq in
2003 its setting is a far cry from the
ghost ships and witch trials featured in
the series thus far tackling a recent
conflict with ramifications that are
still felt to this day
fortunately house of ashes uses the iraq
war as more than a simple backdrop for
jump scares focusing on both sides of
the war as allegiances fall by the
wayside in the face of a more terrifying
threat
much like his predecessors supermass's
latest also uses real myths and
historical events to flesh out
supernatural elements house of ashes
begins in the ancient mesopotamian city
of akkad in 2231 bc with the compelling
prologue that takes inspiration from the
curse of akkad a poem detailing how the
acadian empire was destroyed after its
king naram sin declared himself a god
and plundered the chief god and allele's
temple
naturally this angered the sumerian
deity who exacted revenge by summoning
an invasion from the neighboring gutian
people house of ashes deviates from the
akkadian myth however by making this a
temple to bazouzu the king of the demons
this sinister spin and the appearance of
frightening underground creatures poses
a much greater threat to the remaining
acadians than the attack of goothians
fast forward to 2003 and a mission to
find saddam hussein's non-existent
weapons of mass destruction leads to a
group of marines discovering the
dilapidated sumerian temple and the
monsters hidden within throwing a group
of heavily armed jarheads into a fight
with supernatural miscreations is a
classic genre trope but it's a fresh
perspective for supermassive's brand of
cinematic horror switching from
civilians to soldiers results in a
significant change of pace when you
encounter its antagonists you're still
outmatched and the winged monstrosities
aren't overly fussed by bullets but that
doesn't stop the cast from expending a
veritable bucket load of ammunition
almost every time you meet
house of ashes is never particularly
scary but this has more to do with the
game's design than its cast high-powered
arsenal the narrow confines of the
temple's labyrinthian pathways
intentionally restrict both your
movement and field of vision creating
what would be a harrowing sense of
claustrophobia in almost any other
horror game
the problem is you're never in any
danger when directly controlling a
character
peril only exists during quick time
events so aside from a couple of
well-timed jump scares navigating the
game's cramped arteries is relatively
fright free the creatures are also shown
early and often so any fear of the
unknown is extinguished fairly quickly
with that said the elaborate action
sequences that occur when you're forced
to go toe-to-toe with the monsters make
for the series most exciting and fraught
moments thus far
mechanically your role in these scenes
hasn't changed from little hope there's
a variety of intense qtes that can
potentially impact each character's
lifespan
they're usually pretty short but you're
given a heads up beforehand and it even
lets you know what kind of qte is coming
up next there are consequences to
failing though whether this affects
something down the line or results in a
character's immediate death you never
quite know and this ensures that these
qtes remain nerve-racking throughout the
likability of each character plays a
pivotal role in this perpetual tension
too since you're probably not going to
be nervous if someone you don't care
about is in a perilous situation
on the flip side house of ashes is also
a video game failure is ingrained in us
as something to avoid instead we're
supposed to achieve the highest score
possible so simply trying to keep
everyone alive can negate any feelings
you have for its characters in an
attempt to attain the best possible
ending none of the cast is downright
unlikable however unless you
intentionally heave them in that
direction with your choices it's him
he's early your husband you mean
don't you think it's about time you came
clean
put your clothes back on straighten up
whatever you had it it's got to be over
come on
there are five playable characters with
the story jumping between each of them
at certain intervals eric and rachel are
the weakest of the bunch mainly because
their relationship with one another
covers such well-trodden ground the pair
are married but have been separated for
over a year and eric thinks now is the
best time to work out their issues and
get back together all that time spent
away from each other
i couldn't stop thinking of you
don't you feel the same way
it's inherently dull territory and has
nothing new to say to make their story
feel like anything more than a hackneyed
soap opera fortunately the dynamics
between the rest of the ensemble are
much more compelling the middle east is
rarely used as a video game setting
outside of your typical jingoistic
military shooter and those games usually
aren't interested in presenting both
sides of the conflict they often
perpetuate anti-arab sentiments instead
playing into stereotypes and
dehumanizing tropes that paint arabs as
little more than bloodthirsty insurgents
one of the playable characters in house
of ashes is selim a reluctant soldier in
the iraqi republican guard
rather than lazily branding him a
villain for being on the opposite side
to the americans supermassive does an
excellent job of humanizing selim and
making him someone you'll care about and
want to guarantee survives his
interactions with other characters
result in the game's best and most
poignant moments while some of the
game's other topics including critiques
of the war in iraq justified setting why
is it that no one ever tells it straight
everyone just makes a bull to get by
that's why we're in the sandbox in the
first place right
i just want the truth jason
you will of course steer these
conversations yourself to some degree
supermass's approach to choice and
consequence is still present in house of
ashes although the systems it uses are
as opaque as ever each character has
different personality traits such as
abrasive or commanding that you can
accentuate with your decisions these
traits will sometimes result in
characters acting in a specific way when
you're not controlling them but the game
never tells you how your choices might
affect each trait so displaying all this
information feels unnecessary when your
control over them is a complete
crapshoot your choices are also divided
into head and heart decisions
but again the game never explains what
this means or how it might affect any
potential outcomes the best way to play
it is by simply making choices that feel
right to you it would be nice if the
systems that govern these choices were
less inscrutable or hidden behind the
scenes but they don't detract from the
experience too much
your survival depends on the choices you
make
they will be as a compass
guiding you through the unknown
will you find the path to salvation
or be lost in the darkness
despite these continued missteps house
of ashes represents the peak of the dark
pictures anthology so far its setting in
characters offer a fresh perspective for
the series while supermassive's penchant
for creating tension through something
as simple as a qte is as masterful as
ever it might not be particularly fear
inducing but his action set pieces are
fraught with peril for the fate of its
characters and the final act sticks the
landing with a satisfying payoff the
series might still be stuck in the
smothering shadow of until dawn but
house of ashes is a step in the right
direction
you